Haeju under German sharpshooter with the
Detroit unit for maybe April for the
watches lid orange I traded my Jersey
for play care here nine months later we
moved out to DC this is my sixth mission
the first with this team agent Josh
O'Neill demolitionists for the Baltimore
you I was activated when the lockdown
went into effect this was my 10th
mission agent Genevieve Hendrickson
survivalist with a DC unit I hadn't
fully completed my training when I was
activated but I was excited to jump on
the team and help out this was my second
mission when I met Jenna I was a little
on edge she was clearly an experienced
at this kind of op and then I saw Andre
this towering six foot ten athlete I
mean what does a basketball player know
about intelligence ops I'm used to being
down low and sticking to the shadows I
didn't need this massive target giving
away our position
being big is great for basketball not so
much for ducking behind walls no dodging
bullets
but what a rush start falling apart your
kids took the wall burn
marksmanship demolition first-aid
whatever Harry didn't tell me to do I
did except the shoes I kept my kicks
Josh had interrogated one of the true
sons into giving up actionable Intel
they were definitely after something big
they've taken a heavily fortified
position
our mission was to infiltrate retrieve
Intel and eliminate any hostile presence
there was a high likelihood to see some
real heat I took us about where I knew
I'd operate best up high wide view back
when I was playing almost done much I
was underrated not anymore
I've caught a dude sneaking up on Jen I
fell back to what I know take your time
take a breath
bloody he started shooting before we
were ready worst nightmare I saw you
save Jen's life so I'm picking them up
one by one
bang dun dun dun
I mean I was behind Josh but I don't
know if he just didn't see what was
happening at our left flank he turned
left I said wrong way wrong we go right
go right
I saw it in here the way out
I should have listened to Jen
glad it wasn't me he'll never let me
live that one down that'll work on that
core vision Josh we were essentially
trapped building our own but the
reinforcements coming
we're getting overwhelmed next thing I
know I'm hit just not my day wrong turns
getting shot I think is my first day on
the job he said all that I'm surprised
he admitted that Josh was hit he
couldn't move I was trying to get to the
scene well hadn't you pinned down I
thought that was it
mission failure or dead you know the way
I see things gave that ogre to the time
runs out I jump the banister hit the
ground running all of a sudden I didn't
know behind race Hall and a sports Josh
next thing I know
hungers right there actually up don't
mind the woman left behind I'm not about
to let my team though I mean with one
hand he's dragging me to cover with the
other he's taken out hostels with
pinpoint grenade tosses I guess jump
shot skills can translate to combat wait
he said it was Andre taking people out
guess he didn't see me clean enough of
my cross
oh I saw her core vision baby as they
retreated into one of the collections
rooms
I saw one had an armored suit case we
needed to get that suitcase back to the
base I was down I wasn't out he's
posting up with my m32 they thought they
could hide from my sweet baby I don't
think so John little fools the hell was
m32 we got it we got it we got it we did
a field analysis we found the true sons
were holding on to some real firepower
weapons powerful enough to wreak serious
havoc on the city happy to say that's
the W you couldn't have done this
without our tech dudes a legend
take em on my school at any time
attention all agents u.s. capital is
under attack I repeat the u.s. capital
is under attack
all agents in the vicinity please
respond
[Music]
[Music]